look what's going on in Argentina right
now this is absolutely spectacular this
is from the N wokeness Twitter account
18 days ago president Javier Malay was
inaugurated in Argentina since then
here's what he's done this is
unbelievable eliminated 12 out of 21
cabinet posts firing 5,000 government
employees ending 380,000 government
regulations banned woke language in the
military Bill to affirm the right to
self-defense Bill to legalize
homeschooling of kids proposal to punish
to punish all Riot organizers future
welfare cuts for Road blocking legalized
paying contracts in Bitcoin
privatization of state-run companies
opened up the Argentina oil industry
doesn't that all sound freaking amazing
and it's because the people of Argentina
had gotten so close to the precipice of
true communism and socialism socialism
they had basically dived into it already
they were in that pool and they somehow
figured out how to get out and they're
on their way out and every single bullet
point that I just put up there are the
things that we should be doing here in
the United
States